oh man I don't even know
all right well that's how we do it and
we're here once again and here we go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
to your favorite podcast
[Applause]
first of all happy Valentine's Day
special day special day to celebrate the
loved ones in your life and no one has a
more special loved one than me
you might pop in and make an appearance
so we're gonna talk about Valentine's
Day and we're going to talk about my
Super Bowl recap my whole weekend but
other than that it's just gonna be a fun
time and I wish you well and once again
welcome back
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Roofing with Griffin
everybody as you know we're from Griffin
we're here live everybody that's on uh
YouTube right now watching live I
appreciate you guys being here as always
uh and then everybody listening on all
the audio platforms thanks for being
here for that you know I like to do it
live for one I like going off the cuff
too it's actually easier for production
because it's already ready to go
so I have my reasons but it is what it
is but thank you for being here make
sure you subscribe
share hit the notifications like and all
that good stuff because it really helps
I appreciate that you know I'm on Twitch
daily most days and so check me out of
Eric Griffin gaming you could be a
subscriber there if you want to support
the show that's a great way to support
the show this being a twitch sub but you
can also
be a patreon member I got you know I'm
gonna be doing some more content I got a
bunch of videos that I'm gonna come out
that I'm doing with Rachel so make sure
you guys check that out and uh you know
thanks for being here you know and there
is uh oh let's see if this works boom it
didn't work but whatever
so I
think of difficulties all the time and
that's when you're doing a show by
yourself that's what ends up happening
but before I get started and keep going
I also want to thank uh our sponsor of
the show it's kickoff
want to thank kickoff for being a
sponsor of the show if you're looking to
boost your life and you want to help
build your credit score
kickoff is the one get an amazing credit
score and reward so what are you waiting
for apply right now in minutes at
kickoff.com to start building Better
Credit that's
k-i-k-o-f-f.com to build your credit
score
without the lift start today at
kickoff.com
all right guys it's it is a Valentine's
Day and uh welcoming to the show uh the
Beautiful the vivacious my beautiful
wife Mrs Griffin Rachel welcome to the
show
having me here
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's start off with your Rachel has a
great podcast voice that's what she does
it she's like all right babe you look
lovely we're going out to dinner and I
wanted to bring you on for uh you know a
little while remember we're live so you
know how that goes you know what I mean
thank you I love your pink shirt that I
got for you it looks great on you
it does look great on me but I brought
Rachel on because well first of all
you know we oh something's up I'm not
gonna worry about it right now uh I I
just get anal about like what it the
thing looks like you know because it's
like there's always it never looks the
way you want it to look man the the key
threshold thing you know what I mean
honestly that's how I feel about my hair
babe your hair looks great yeah yeah but
there's always something you know oh you
know what you're right we are the same
in that way that's crazy that we look at
things like that the same yeah I just
wonder if it's like the the the the
green screen thing was messing up but
anyways
um
okay so it's like what to get for
Valentine's Day so I wanted I wanted to
get let me just tell you something about
Rachel while she's on the screen right
now so Rachel one of the things I love
about her she likes to do research so
even if I say hey I want to buy you
something then she doesn't like
surprises because she likes to pick
right babe yeah but I also if I'm gonna
spend money on something I want to make
sure that I really love it okay right so
she does a lot of like research so
she'll like go on the website so if I
say hey I know you want this Gucci purse
because she wanted a Gucci purse so then
she went to the website and she like now
it's like three hours of Gucci research
and then she sends me first the most
outlandish purse
you know it actually wasn't the most
outlandish the last photo was the most
outlandish it was like thirty one
thousand dollars
[Laughter]
but the first one was like okay let's
not even talking about 300. no the first
one was like 6 500 and I'm like you
ain't getting a 6500 for Valentine's Day
that's what Gucci has to offer no they
have other
why do you have to go to the website and
then then sort by most expensive I don't
I actually really
um well first I sorted by newest
but
oh really
sort by newest is that is that really
what you do yeah but then I just wanted
to look at all of them because I'm not
trying to buy the most expensive but the
ones I like are usually the most
expensive oh what am I noticing me I
just have really good taste of what I
the quality and type I like well I also
I just I don't want just a plain purse
that you're gonna spend all this money
on that you can get at Target or Walmart
or like well that sounds like those
sound like great persons
for me targeted Walmart purse is what
are you hating on target at Walmart no
I'm not because I wear them but
if I'm gonna get
uh quality purse that I love that I can
like you know if you're spending all
this money on it then you want to make
sure that you're gonna it's not just
like seasonal It's Gonna Last you
forever and you're gonna
what are you doing nothing
I could see you over here busted
baby we get it okay so Rachel got me a
gift I'm still gonna get her we're going
to dinner I'm not gonna tell you where
we went when we leave here we got to go
to dinner so I actually got to finish up
it's gonna be like a not as long episode
as normally but Rachel got me something
for Valentine's Day and I'm gonna open
it up live on the podcast so you ready
babe yeah I think you'll really love it
okay all right so it's always wrapped
very nicely
okay you know but let me show you the
box there's the Box you know the the bag
very lovely stuff okay wait there's a
lot of stuff
all right first up is
good uh a spoon set oh you got me a new
baby spoon yeah
but they're not baby spoons they're
adult
spoons
they're baby spoons they're just small
spoons but they're adult spoons yes and
if you guys remember back in the podcast
from many episodes ago Rachel threw away
my baby spoon and it was a whole thing
and she's finally replacing it oh these
are great little honey spoons yeah
they're honey spoons oh because we like
honey in our coffee babe thank you I
love you you're welcome I knew you would
love it and there's something else in
here let's see
oh I love it this is my new obsession
which is coffee bugs
you are the best oh You're simply the
best better than all the rest really you
singing live okay
you started it
I should have got her to sing in my ears
all right um babe thank you for the this
and thank you for the honey spoons I
appreciate you yep your next coffee is
gonna be extra special and you know and
I I get obsessive about this too
um I I like so now this is my new coffee
mug so I had a big coffee mug and then I
got that I went on Marc maron's what the
WTF podcast and he gave me a mug and
then I was using that for a long time
and then we went on our honeymoon and I
got I got a coffee mug there I was using
that one and then Rachel bought us some
uh coffee mugs that have an r and an e
on it so then I'm using my e one and my
R and her well you know when you're not
home I like to I like to drink out of
you again
and then I now I have my you're the best
coffee mug so I'm for sure gonna be
drinking out of that one so
babe thank you for uh being here unless
you want to stay a little longer it's up
to you you're welcome you know
um I'll stay a little bit oh oh look at
her getting comfortable
I mean I don't have a gift to open so
you could
but we're gonna go to a very nice dinner
and I bought myself some chocolate
covered strawberries wow
this is how you gonna do me wow I get I
can't even believe it right now this is
hype okay and it's fine babe you said
you
okay so you're not gonna We're not gonna
talk about how yesterday you were like
you don't want the Gucci purse just I
didn't because nothing I hate Gucci
mouth that's what she does no every time
I look at the Gucci website I just it's
not necessarily my style and so I try to
like what's your style if that's not
your style I don't know what my style is
but it's it's not necessarily Gucci
Gucci is just too extreme
it's like too weird it's too hipster
honestly
yeah
okay I don't know what that means it
means it's like too weird like I mean
it's it's luxury and it's like expensive
but it's like all right you know what
they're old school stuff like 10 20
years ago was way better all right you
can't you can't see this but
um I'll wait hold on a second you you
won't be able to see it are you showing
the purses well yeah I want to go to the
the website let me go to the Gucci
website Gucci like I like the stuff that
they show on the runway shows and stuff
but unless you have the full outfit or
the you know the full look
it's like pieces of it it's like hard to
wear okay hold on a second
are you telling me you hear how you hear
how how she works so you're saying you
can't just have a Gucci purse if you
don't have the Gucci stuff to go with it
the Gucci purse is uh useless is that
what we're saying right now no it's just
like the the cheapest Gucci purse isn't
necessarily the one you want it's like
the the one you see on the runway show
that you love is like this the 61 000
the 31 000 purse are you
are you crazy right now well a little
bit because I probably would never buy
that purse but that's the purse I want
oh man it's not working properly
because I didn't have that set up right
it's okay did you guys go to the Gucci
website but Rachel can I ask you
something all the persons seem to look
the same they have like the the the
image the whatever the logo is on the
front of the purse like Louis Vuitton
does that uh what's that one you have LV
whatever Li what is that one Louie no
the other one the the black purse
um YSL YSL they have YSL on it Gucci has
Gucci on the Louis Vuitton is Louis
Vuitton on it but
I learned my lesson is like when you get
a logo on front if it's too big
there's like too much like metal part
then it gets scratched too easily really
quickly and then it doesn't look good
and so like
yeah
all right baby should look at this
camera right there there you go sorry I
just keep looking at you how are you
looking at me where am I there's a
camera up there oh
that's mine and I can see you otherwise
I feel like I'm not talking to anyone oh
okay you're talking to the people out
there but Happy Valentine's Day to
everyone and this is one of my favorite
holidays I love wearing pink I love
wearing red I love love
I love love I do
she does
she loves love and we love Rachel all
right babe I love you so much and let me
finish this podcast and we will go to
dinner uh everybody say goodbye to Mrs
Griffin bye
I know it's hot in here can you turn the
AC on babe
yeah because I needed to start babe I'm
live on my podcast can you not be man
see me going in huh y'all
all right well that was the Rachel
portion of the podcast
um you know I'll have her zip on more
often but you know it is what it is but
you know what while we're talking about
stuff let's talk about kick y'all kick
you got to get that credit score up
y'all your credit score is super
important and you don't even realize how
it affects your life and kickoff is here
to help you get that credit score in
gear if you're ready to take the next
step in your life whether it's buying a
new car or moving into a different
apartment or even buying a house the
first step is a having a healthy credit
score kickoff can help you take control
of your credit so your score doesn't get
in the way of your goals all right
they have plenty of plans plans start at
five dollars a month and every every
one-time payment you make with kickoff
is reported to the major credit bureau
so look at that when they see healthy
habits you have a happier credit score I
mean listen this is really important and
a lot of people don't understand how
credit works and the credits like you
know how much credit do you totally have
so one of my tips for you is like if you
have two credit cards if you only have
one credit card for instance let's say
you have one credit card and you have a
500 balance and you only have one credit
card and that's all your source of
credit now you're using 50 of your
credit because you have a 500 balance
what you need is two credit cards say
they're both thousand thousand dollar
thousand dollar balances and you have a
500 balance on one of them now you're
only using 25 of your total credit that
kind of stuff goes into play and they
help you get all that stuff in in gear
so you understand what's going on so get
your credit score up man kickoff has
also been praised by Big Time names like
Forbes and nerd wallet as a smart way to
build your credit fast all right so so
what are you waiting for apply right now
in minutes at kickoff.com to start
building Better Credit that's
k-i-k-o-f-f.com to build your credit
score
start today at kickoff.com
all right y'all I know that I know that
my uh uh what it is my thing doesn't
work I can't go to those things that I
wanted to show you guys but I wanted to
just talk about uh
um you know Valentine's Day is a great
day and I know some people were like
anti-valentines they're like oh this is
just a corporate America trying to you
know whatever it is what it is it's just
it's a great day to also just celebrate
love that's all it is you know you know
you can celebrate love every single day
but this is that special day where you
go we're going to celebrate love even
more today so Valentine's Day is a good
day and especially when you have someone
a loved one in your life to help you out
so this is great so I have my I have my
my honey spoons I got my honey spoons
and I have my new coffee mug so shout
out to Rachel for that I appreciate that
very greatly so let's see I was in New
York this past weekend
I went to New York and shout out to the
Bell House in Brooklyn we got a nice
little crowd um but I'm Gonna Keep
building go back out there then I did
the seller on so the Friday I was in
Brooklyn Saturday I went to The Cellar
New York's a fun place it's different
you know because like you know I kind of
established myself here in La so I'm one
of the dudes in L.A you know you go to
the county store at any place you go to
the major clubs in La Laugh Factory
Improv Comedy Store and even the ice
house is about to open up I'm in at
these places you coming to town I'm you
know it's like oh oh Eric Griffin's out
such and such you know New York I don't
really have it like that so I gotta
establish myself there more so I do want
to go to New York more because it's just
a different comedy scene it's a
different sensibility different and I
like that I just like it there was some
funny cats out there that I saw so shout
out to the seller for uh you know giving
me a spot
um yeah so that was fun and then I went
to Vegas uh so me and my boy Jeff uh
long time best friend uh shout out to
Jeff chanette we uh we go to we've been
going to Vegas every single year for
like 25 years man we go to Vegas you
know so we went to the Vegas for the
Super Bowl and it's it's amazing how
much has changed over the years but
before I even talk about that can I just
talk about something like this other
thing that happened so a buddy of mine
was setting me setting up a gig for me
you know he was like he's a comic I
won't even say who because I don't want
to like this is like my personal
business but I'm not gonna say names
because you know anyways he goes yo man
there's this gig we could both do it but
I know you're you know I'm a little bit
more well-known than he is but it don't
matter he uh he tries to set the gig up
right and then the guy is not getting
back to us you know because it's like in
Vegas we gotta fly to Vegas so it's like
it's hard to get a hold of this guy he
hasn't said yes or no he decides he
don't want to spend money on two Comics
so my boy's like you know you could just
do it and I'm like why don't you just do
it but anyway sorry I finally get a hold
of the guy and we're talking on the
phone right and he's telling me about
the gig it's sort of a corporate gig for
like and they're doing an event for the
company and all this stuff and he's like
we're gonna do it like this we're gonna
have basketball we're gonna have all
this stuff and then we're gonna have you
do a show and so I'm trying to get a
gauge of like Okay so so what kind of
show is it is it like you know you want
me to make fun of the the heads you know
what I mean like what what are you
looking for you're looking for a real
comedy show you look at you know the
kind of thing and then the guy says he
goes yeah okay but um just uh you know
when you're doing a show uh you know uh
we want we don't want um yeah you know
you don't don't say we don't want you
saying things like [__] or [__] those
are like the two words he picked right
just randomly like you know we don't we
don't get down like that that's how he
says it like you know our company we
don't get down like that I immediately
took offense like when people do this
here's the thing if you're gonna book a
comic for a show and you want a clean
show then you say hey it's it's uh
family friendly so we just we want all
clean but when you start to pick and
choose like certain words when you're
like okay so do your show the way you do
it just don't say these two words go
[__] yourself that's what I say to that
you know what I mean so I got a little
bit of a tune on the phone because I'm
like yo man that's out of context
context matters when you're saying
things you know because if you're like
oh man uh I was I I was acting like a
[__] or you know it's there's certain
ways you could say words that it's not
crass or lewd you know uh which would
change the context of like the the
making the words okay you know what I'm
trying to say it's it's a it's a whole
thing so then you know we're kind of
going back and forth and he's like you
know getting an attitude with me it's
like because everybody thinks they're
important you know what I mean it's like
by the way I'm doing you a favor you
know what I'm saying like even if you're
paying me I'm still I did like this
ain't a real show there's no artistic
value in going this is all for money
that I don't need by the way so I'm like
all right I thought I was going to do
the show with my friend and then I
couldn't do the show with my friend
because he didn't even want to pay him
so now I'm like and I'm just going to do
a show and I'm kind of like okay so he's
hitting me with all these like and then
we kind of go like well you know then he
says this he goes I go he goes well you
gotta get it if I would stay with my
friends but I would never say those
words in front of a thousand people and
I was like because your dumb ass ain't a
comic you know you acting like a [__]
[__]
see there's an example of how the words
could be used anyways I'm feeling like
it's getting weird on the phone so I try
to be like hey man if you want what I
get what you want I've done churches
I've done all kinds of shows it'll be
fine just you know anyways
one o'clock two o'clock in the morning I
get a text from the guy you know what I
mean and he's I actually already deleted
it because I don't want his dumbass
number in my phone
he's all like yeah you know I didn't
like that conversation that we had so
um we're I'm gonna I'm going I'm getting
a different comic we're going in a
different direction uh you know have a
nice day blah blah blah I just I just
hit him with the like on this thing like
bye like dude it's that just I'm just
venting I'm venting is it okay if I vent
you know that's what it's like
stuff that pisses me off you know what I
mean I'm complaining about something I
just I didn't appreciate his tone his
attitude the whole thing was like
whatever I was contentious I realized if
I really wanted to do the gig I would
have been like no problem dude it's
gonna be fun because I know when I get
there it doesn't even matter like when
somebody says that kind of stuff as a
comic you go to the show and you go like
oh hey uh so and so he was he he said I
couldn't say these words uh what do you
guys think and everybody would have been
like say yeah I mean you know how to get
around that but I honestly just was like
I had I didn't appreciate him you know
it's like he's I didn't I just didn't
appreciate the whole the whole
interaction you know especially when
you're talking about you're paying for
art you know I'm giving you people think
that it's just like hey go up here and
be a clown go up here and just like you
know entertain us well I I do that my
brand and if you don't want my brand
don't hire me you understand that's how
it works but don't hire a brand and then
tell them to do something different it's
like you don't hire McDonald's to cater
your thing and be like yeah that no no
Burgers
um yeah we don't do that here uh we want
uh all healthy it's like you hired
McDonald's [__] you know what I
mean you hire McDonald's you give me
McDonald's okay
same thing if you you know even if it's
some like you know you're ordering from
some fancy sushi place and you get the
sushi and you're like yeah no raw stuff
it's like know what you're getting bro
yeah have a nice day at 1am was a that
was a middle finger to me so from me to
you bro if you ever watch this
two middle fingers for you you know what
I mean
[Laughter]
maybe I'm just mad and I'm just venting
on my on my platform because I can you
know what I mean but it's just
ridiculous you know whole thing is
ridiculous but anyways all right let's
get to the let's get to it guys why this
episode is really all about let's just
give my Super Bowl recap so me and my
boy Jeff we've been going to Vegas for
so many years and it has changed
dramatically man Vegas has changed
dramatically when it comes to like going
to the Super Bowl to watch the Super
Bowl so we used to go and at first I
remember it like not be like people were
there to bet but then it became a thing
where like watching the game at the
sports book is actually cool because
they got all these TVs and there's a
bunch of people there and so for the
first few years we would go the sports
book you it's first come first serve and
then eventually it turned into they were
like yo people actually like watching it
here they would rope it off and then
they would charge money like if you
wanted to sit at the Sportsbook you
needed to get a reservation and then
like you know pay a certain amount of
money to sit in a sports book so then
that was like whatever so then like I'm
a part of the rewards programs and then
the rewards programs the the hotels they
started having these big parties they
were Super Bowl parties so they would be
in these big rooms big screen big
projector TV and then they would have
free food and all this kind of stuff and
so there'd be a price for that so then
you can watch the game like that we did
that a couple times but I actually
didn't like it because the food was
always whack and now you stuck and you
know you're like
so then
as we go as we got older now we're older
so then it goes like this we go to Vegas
we make our bats we we get our slips
that's what we like to do we get to like
the paper that has all the parlay bats
all the nonsense parlay bets so we would
go we get our parlay bets and we sit we
have lunch and we like figure out like
oh okay who's gonna score the first
touchdown the coin toss all these
ridiculous bets like who's gonna have
more yards who's gonna they have so many
great prop bats and we would sit there
figure that out fill out all the sheets
go stand in the long line at the sports
book and then we would like make our
bets you know and then like you know we
would watch the game sometimes we would
just stand outside the sports book
because you can still watch the game and
everybody's like there's TVs everywhere
you're yelling and cheering with
everybody you watch the dumb commercials
and then half time would come we go to
the room we watch sort of watch the
halftime show of whoever it is fall
asleep in the third quarter wake up in
the fourth quarter as we got older
because we're both older and then we
finished the game in the room and then
we go see if we won we take our tickets
to the winnings this year it was
completely it's really different now I
think after the pandemic people aren't
going to Vegas as much as they did
before but what's really happening too
is everything's moved online so we were
at Mandalay Bay which is a part of the
Caesar's rewards uh MGM uh conglomerate
of whatever that is and so they had this
thing called MGM bet you know so then
now you don't even need to go to the
sports book
they have these machines that you
deposit money into the machines and now
it goes to your account
and all the prop bets and everything is
right on your phone you can even live
bet you know sounds like a commercial
but it's not I'm just telling you how
things have changed so now we now we're
just sitting on our phone but now we go
to the sports book and it's it's half
empty you know like there's people
sitting in all the chairs that you can
sit in and even during the game there
was empty chairs and stuff and it was
just like it was like we were just
standing there like man five six years
ago there's we would not be able to
stand right where we are right now you
know what I mean we wouldn't be able to
stand and watch the game so we're just
talking with people and watching the
game and it was like a super exciting
game and then it was just like you know
we're walking around we go we went to
like this one restaurant so after the
first half was about to end we went over
to this restaurant because it was like
five it was this sushi restaurant that
was about to open up and they were only
going to serve and we go there no one's
in there they got TVs at the bar
literally there was like two people at
the bar and we're just like wow we can
just sit here eat sushi and watch the
game game no way I'm telling you five
years ago this whole bar would have been
jam-packed with people and they would
have been because we passed by we were
at um Mandalay Bay so we passed by the
House of Blues it was empty there was
like a splattering of people at the bar
the the restaurant side there was
practically no one there and you know I
say oh why don't we just go sit and have
a some snacks because we were going to a
steak dinner later I go let's go over
here have some snacks we walk up to the
the thing and the lady said oh okay yeah
well if you want to sit here it's 250 a
person man I laughed in her [__] face
250 no thank you I can just stand right
here and watch I don't anyways we go
over to the sushi bar and then they just
let us sit there and we're talking with
them and they're telling us how yeah
we tried this last year because because
they weren't open when the game started
so I asked the lady behind the bar I go
why didn't you guys open for the game
and she was like we tried it last year
and no one was here I was like wow so we
sat we watched the the halftime show and
then you know we we actually watched the
rest of the game sitting right there you
know we had a couple of rolls and then
as soon as the game ended we went over
to strip steak had a steak dinner and it
was great but it's just weird how Vegas
is different and I don't know what
that's from I'd love to hear what you
guys think in the chat or in the
comments like is it like
is the world so different now because of
at post pandemic and also how everything
is moved online because if you think
about it right now you could go to Vegas
you know you don't you could get like a
a big ass Suite watch the game in the
suite and you don't have to worry about
going downstairs to the sports book
because you got the app or you could
Airbnb a nice house in Vegas uh barbecue
do all the stuff you're gonna do have a
bunch of people over watch the game like
that like it's it seems to be it's like
so different now uh how people are
interacting with each other it's not as
important to do things like that I don't
know it just looked like man I'm like
this is only going to get worse is there
are they even gonna there won't be any
sports books because you'll just be able
to do everything on your on on the
computer there's gonna be no human
interaction I don't know it just was uh
it was a strange thing and I'm just
curious to see what you guys uh might
think of it you know so anyways let's go
over to game
um first let's go to the 10 fool hat
people not tin foil tin fool you're a
tin fool if you think the Super Bowl was
fixed like shut up like I don't want to
hear it man
in 1918 or whatever that was when they
tried to
fix the World Series
it was found out at a time when there
was no internet there was no mass
communication they just had papers and
telephones and that's it and they found
out about it
do you think that the entire NFL
of people
all right
and it's fixed and it wouldn't come out
first of all Antonio Brown would have
ratted him out think of all the
disgruntled NFL players you know
they would have found a way for it to
get out even if it's not from them like
there's no way you could keep a secret
of that magnitude that oh we're gonna
script it and when did they practice the
met the press and media have been around
the teams for the two weeks you know
like when would they practice oh let's
script out everything that's gonna
happen if you believe that you're a let
me let me curse at you you're a [__]
idiot anybody that believes that
professional sports is completely fixed
and scripted is a [__] idiot there's
no way there's just no way now are there
people that are trying to manipulate the
outcome because of gambling and money
interest yeah probably and they're
trying to weed those people out but they
get found out referees get caught
players get caught it's just no way you
could keep a magnitude of that hidden
for so freaking long so I don't know
it's just I don't believe it I don't
believe it it's my opinion you don't you
think it's fixed go ahead you keep your
tin fool hat on but not me
let me hear what you guys say in the
comments
but anyways great game so
you guys know if you watched your
podcast I originally thought that
Cincinnati would go to the Super Bowl
and the 49ers would go to the Super Bowl
and I thought Cincinnati would win
that didn't happen Cincinnati lost to
Kansas City and the 49ers had bad luck
they they Eagles took them out but they
also had a considerable amount of bad
luck with Prague party getting hurt the
the other quarterback getting hurt not
having an extra quarterback it just we
were it was so disappointing of the game
so you cut to this game and I thought
from last week I thought Patrick Mahomes
is going to win this game I just thought
Legacy is on the line
the dude here's the talk people are
doubting him you know they everybody was
talking about how Joe burrow has already
beaten him three times is Joe Pearl
better so he had to stomp him out and
then he heard the talk he's had two bad
Super Bowls you know even the Super Bowl
that he won he didn't have a great game
he had a great fourth quarter and in the
and in the next Super Bowl he was in he
lost to Tom Brady the offensive line was
decimated but he didn't have a great
game
cut to this game the dude was a monster
monster the stats don't he didn't have
great gaudy stats but the dude had his
fingerprints all over this game
they won because of him
uh primarily because of him but it was
also a great team effort I think the
whole team
played well I thought the chief's
offensive line dominated the game he
didn't get touched he didn't get
pressured he didn't get rushed
the chief's offensive line heard that
talk how can they fight they won't be
able to stop the Eagles defense with all
these all Pros third most sacks in NFL
history in the season so they heard all
that talk that they want so they stepped
up right then it was like you know the
receivers were were they can't handle
these uh these these uh uh cornerbacks
those receivers did their job
Patrick Holmes was dotting it up all
over the field so
I think that Patrick Mahomes as the
leader of the team he willed them to
Victory
I mean he did okay
but I'll say this
the the
Kansas City offense like let's compare
the teams okay this is what's crazy
about this game y'all and it's just my
football analysis as a fan I'm not I'm
no expert okay I'm not claiming to be
either
as a fan I'm just talking as a fan and
as an observer of the game
if you look on paper who played better
the Eagles offense was better than the
Kansas City offense
the Eagles offense scored more points
than the Kansas City offense the Eagles
offense was Unstoppable they had
one mistake on offense
uh one major mistake I'm saying that was
the Jalen hurts fumble and he's still so
let's look at it the Eagles offense
including quarterback Jalen hurts
you look at his numbers he had a way
better game than Patrick Mahomes three
rushing touchdowns uh uh a passing
touchdown a two-point conversion over
300 yards the dude was bawling right I
think he had over 300 yards but he had
70 yards rushing it just was a complete
game the dude looked like oh he gonna
get paid oh Jalen hurts he gonna get
paid y'all he gonna get his money so he
the great the offense whenever they
needed to score they needed to score
defensively
they this is one of those things where
defense win does win championships
because Rich defense was better
which defense special teams like that's
a combination defense and special teams
what defense and special teams played
better
it was clearly the Chiefs they got a
scoring touchdown they got that um that
monstrous run back that got him to the
five which led to an easy touchdown
I mean they held they they did all they
could to keep
uh them from from scoring and they still
it was so close like it's just a couple
of plays on special teams and defense
that the Chiefs did better but the
Eagles defense
oh
the Eagles defense this vaunted defense
man
did nothing they just they got beat down
man the Eagles defense let that team
down they did and then so cut to that
last play and look you want to say all
you want to say about the Eagles defense
and like that call the holding call
against James Bradberry is that the
guy's name yeah the the the the
cornerback look the dude said it himself
he was like yeah I held the guy and his
his how I feel about 50 50 on it
it was holding and he should have called
holding but to me
the past like if the past was closer to
being caught
then you throw the flag
so you know what I mean like
the guy's running he's being held
they're fighting they're hold but the
pass was so overthrown the dude wasn't
gonna catch it anyway so then you leave
it but if
at that point of the play you see it and
you go up no the dude would have caught
that if it wasn't for the holding then
you call it that's what I think
that's what I think
so it's just one of those plays
it was holding you know but we were
robbed see that's the thing about it we
as fans were like oh didn't you want to
see
the the eagle stopped them
Philly I mean Chiefs kick a field goal
and then
Jalen hurts gets the ball with like a
minute 50 with one time out let's see
what you got youngster can you take him
down the field and score and win this
game we would want to see that we would
have wanted to see that man that would
have been great but sadly we didn't the
dude made a mistake you don't hold in
that situation he shouldn't have done
that he shouldn't have done it because
in his mind he made a calculation he was
like but I get it too like he was about
to get beat the dude was beat so he was
like oh man oh that's a great move I I
can't let you get this touchdown in my
opinion yeah hold him get the penalty so
they're not in the end zone so you know
I get that but at the same time
practicing my home's just flung that and
it just really looked like even if the
dude would have went clean and not held
him I don't think Juju would have got
there to catch that ball so it's one of
those plays that's the one black mark
the one blemished on an absolutely
fabulous Super Bowl like that was a
great game man when when the Eagles came
back and scored that when they were down
eight and they scored that touchdown and
got the two-point conversion I was like
oh this is this is a battle like this is
a battle this isn't like we've seen so
many terrible Super Bowls in the past
five six seven years man they're all
garbage garbage it's like a blowout and
then like maybe that one when Brady came
back and it was like to come back
against Atlanta when he was in Japan but
that was like to me Atlanta run the ball
what do you do that was just stupidity
on Atlanta's part and that was a boring
Super Bowl up until the fourth quarter
so many boring wins oh how about that
boring
oh the the Patriots Rams was that the
Patriots
three-point scored ugh
that was just absolutely ridiculous you
know
so this was an absolutely fantastic
um it was fantastic it was a really
great Super Bowl and the league looks
like it's in good hands man
um but you know like I say the Chiefs
offensive line dominated that was a
great point to the game uh Jalen like I
said Jalen hurt showed he is a number
one he's qb1 he's a QB one
he was Unstoppable right he really was
and it's a shame we didn't get to see
him
do his thing and also to me the other
winner was Andy Reed and Eric bienemy
they dialed up like two times the
receiver was wide open that's coaching
and preparation so the Eagles got out
coached in every aspect of the game
other than not every aspect because the
chief's defense they couldn't stop them
the Eagles could score whenever they
want it you know it would have went back
and forth but the eagle the Chiefs
defense did enough they capitalized on
the mistakes and the special teams won
the game you know what I mean it was
great
uh it wasn't like I say it was a
controversial finish but it is what it
is you know
uh oh and by the way you think about
this too the kicker Kansas City the
kicker missed the field that field goal
I mean it was so many different things
that went on this game
um and also the the field I didn't I
thought that the Super Bowl field was
like what's going on this is a the most
watched television show every single
year it's the most watched television
show get the field in order man what the
[__] was that about that that I thought
was ridiculous okay so another big
things in the game
um my takeaways from the game is Patrick
Mahomes needed to win this game he
needed to win the game so he can
establish himself as one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time and he has five
straight AFC appearances three Super
Bowl appearances two wins two Super Bowl
MVPs I believe he has three two or three
League MVPs is it two is it three I
think it's just two but regardless
he can retire right now and he's going
to the Hall of Fame that's the kind of
career he's had okay let's just put it
on put it there all right
um and he's only 27 years old but to
talk about him as a great he needed to
win another Super Bowl so now whatever
happens after this he's just adding to a
stellar resume trying to work towards
people saying is that the greatest
quarterback of all time he's got to keep
going he's got to get more wins but he's
working on it so we like to see him work
on it that was my takeaway from that I
thought of Jalen hurts lost a game and
didn't play well it was going to really
hurt him but to me that dude established
himself as pay me my 40 million dollars
a year uh ASAP y'all
so I thought that was great
um you know what else is going on in the
game
um it's just I don't know I don't even
know what to I I just it just really was
a fantastic game you know uh Kudo and
shout out to the Chiefs oh and I I
entertainment my bets let me tell you
about my bets yes I forgot about this so
my bad I bet that the Chiefs would score
five touchdowns so they had to have five
touchdowns not six not seven not four it
had to be exactly five touchdowns so I
won that bet
and then I bet that this is one of those
prop bets I bet that
um the first score would be
a touchdown
a passing touchdown I got that bad and
then I bet
um on the Chiefs and the over and then I
had another bet just on the Chiefs and
so I won all those bets so I want a
little bit of money
so I could buy Rachel purse so
yeah so anyways that was pretty uh that
was pretty good all right so
the um halftime show let's go what the
halftime show so I was gonna I was gonna
show you this but it's like my thing
isn't working because you know it was
such a stressing setup to set the camera
up to so I can have Rachel on was such a
hassle okay but I it took me like 45
minutes and I wanted to be done already
like I gotta go we have dinner
reservations so we gotta go so Trump was
going in on Rihanna's Super Bowl
performance which I don't understand we
were sitting in that sushi restaurant I
was telling you about and and we
couldn't hear the sound we heard like
from other TVs in the casino we heard
the sound but we didn't hear it so we
saw her and I was like I was like what's
Rihanna doing like you know what I mean
like she looked like
how Aretha Franklin started to look as
like we got to look like an old woman
but still doing it you know what I mean
like she wasn't doing like you know all
this she was just chill and I was like
oh [__] this is who she gonna be when
she's like 58 still out on the road and
I was wondering why she was doing that
and then it turns out people were
Googling it looks like oh she pregnant
so she was pregnant and still gave a
really great performance like Rihanna's
got that thing you know I don't know
what it is but she got that it Factor so
she was just kind of gliding around and
like it was it was funny you know
but it's great to like you know
any
like nobody it's it just was it just it
just was like you know I'm not a huge I
know a few of her songs you know I'm not
like a big Rihanna fan like that uh I
think she's a great personality and I
know more about her because of Rachel
and Fendi her her you know her her
fashion like she's a fashion model now I
don't even think she really is she even
a musician anymore she's like such a
fashion Mogul but Trump you look like a
fool man like you look like a fool like
you're like what a petty bitter [__] to
be mad at Rihanna for whatever she said
and then to attack her performance
really you gotta attack the the pregnant
black woman on Super Bowl Sunday because
you don't like her like it's like you
look stupid man the guy looks dumb I
thought that was like let that one go
man take that L take that L man
I don't know they just was dumb but it
was just it was interesting to see like
you know
like I wonder at what point did she know
that oh this is performance isn't going
to go the way we want like when she
showed up to rehearsal did they have
like a bigger plan for her to do more
stuff and then they just said she was
like yeah I'm not gonna be able to do
that anymore so just have a lot of
dancers around me now because I'm just
gonna be like you know shine bright like
a diamond you know what I mean she was
so chill
it is funny how she was just floating
around you know what I mean like she
just like looked like Cher now like Cher
does that you know what I mean so it was
cool
it was crazy so shout out to Rihanna in
the halftime show that was pretty good
um you know what guys I think uh I gotta
go to I gotta take my wife out to uh I'm
gonna take my wife out to to to dinner
y'all I gotta take my wife out to dinner
I want to thank y'all for watching
riffing with Griffin I want to thank you
for listening to referend with Griffin
um you know thank you for the support as
always like I say subscribe share uh
look at look for me on uh twitch and
Twitter and and uh and all that uh you
know twitch look for me even on air
Griffin gaming on YouTube check me out
on that because I'm I'm on that a lot
too so you know
and I appreciate you guys uh being here
as always but you know what we do to end
the show
that rap recap
that's how we do it on Valentine's Day
oh yeah
cat racer on the show
now we gotta go
do it Gucci slow
Rock array hit this flow
MVP
[Music]
on the outside can you see
Rihanna
[Music]
[Applause]
MVP
[Music]
I needed more beats on that
well that's the rap recap y'all and I
thank you for being here on with Griffin
and I will see you next
week
peace y'all